[Music]
we all have desires
even if they remain hidden from us
[Music]
but it is your story and
i cannot wait to see where it goes
movies take us into those places that we
often think about in life
death love mortality
and music is the undercurrent of those
stories
[Music]
hello guys thank you so much for being
here this morning george and i have been
working for almost a year just to write
the melody for this movie so i hope you
guys have as much fun playing it as i'm
gonna have listening to you
our composer tom hulkenberg also known
as junkie excel who i first had the
privilege of working with on fury road
has a very comprehensive understanding
of music
and he understood that this film had to
evoke a magical feeling about the
wonders and catastrophes of this world
we wanted to create one singular theme
which holds everything that surrounds
love
it should feel like this melody was
always here and this melody will always
be
there's no story about wishing that is
not a cautionary tale his sound is
unbelievably fresh and free
he knows where to up the emotion where
to lower when to become quiet when to
get loud
working with george keeps you
open-minded is a dynamic process and you
force yourself to constantly create
something new
tom worked so hard on bringing that
sonic landscape
with all its majesties and sorrow
it allows you to lose yourself in the
story from the opening credits until the
end and that's why it needs to be
experienced in the cinema
i have a wish
[Music]
you